for their contributions in furthering
the design and refinement of the Texas
Instruments dlp cinema projection
technology the Academy presents the
scientific and engineering award to Brad
Walker Scott de Walden bill Werner Greg
Pettit and Frank poor radish gentlemen
please join us on the stage
okay I get to talk first I want to thank
the Academy for this honor we all really
appreciate it it took a huge group of
folks to make all this happen so we're
really accepting this on their bath this
effort has been going on since 1992 okay
there was a lot of leadership at TI back
in those days Jack Herod Bob England
John Nance coder and more recently ken
Novak so it took a lot of vision to kind
of make this happen it took a lot of
really smart folks to make this happen
and it was a lot of fun there's a lot of
stories that it's hard to remember after
all this time but we're trying to put
back together some of these stories and
maybe it'll make a movie script Sunday
what do you think we we have sexy you
know of acronyms and things too and
telecentric lenses were popular earlier
we got two of them in every projector
you know so I don't know anyway Doug
Darrow couldn't be here tonight Paul
Breedlove couldn't be here tonight these
were guys that worked with the Hollywood
community along with Dave Duncan to you
know translate engineering into
Hollywood speak because there was a gap
there for a while so we had to figure
all that stuff out but they did a real
good job with it so anyway thanks again
to the Academy and for all those who
helped
last time we had a word about five years
ago I shot it out to the mechanical
engineers a lot of people who made it
happen there was a time when the
contrast of the dlp projector was not
where they wanted to be and one of my
friends coworker Josh Jacobs nya came up
with a technique to improve the contrast
you know one of those names is not
they're not up here tonight but critical
to making what it is today so I'd like
to thank the Academy also texas
instruments for allowing us to work on
this project also all the other members
of the dlp team without whom we couldn't
have made it possible also my wife
Connie and Brittany and Ryan are here
with me my children so I thank everyone
20 years ago when I first started
working on this technology I certainly
never would have dreamed that it be used
to project movies on over a hundred
thousand screens around the world nor
enable some of the 3d movies and high
frame rate movies as well I'd like to
thank dr. Larry Hornbeck for developing
the digital micromirror device without
this device this technology would not
have been possible so I thank you Larry
and I thank thank you for this award
just want to add thanks to the
perseverance of texas instruments and
the projector manufacturers that use DLP
cinema technology and to my wife linda
and also to matt callen and lauren
nielsen who were essential for the
development of dlp cinema thank
I'm an idiot I'm an idiot i forgot to
thank my wife Carrie and my son